welcome back planning on selling your
home this year do you have questions
harvey blankfeld in las vegas real
estate now who is sponsoring this
segment they have the answers welcome
back harvey good to see you buddy thanks
for having me back hey listen before we
start i got to say i'm sorry i didn't
bring any whiskey because you had
champagne you had beer whiskey would
have been a trifecta uh it's 3 40. we've
got 20 minutes all right you're
connected man make some calls
what should i consider if i'm selling my
home this year what's the main i should
get okay always the consideration is
sometimes it's time versus money because
they're inversely proportional the more
time it takes the more money you get
sometimes so you want to think about do
i want to sell to an i buyer an
institutional buyer one of those big
companies that advertises on tv for an
easy sale or do i want to take a more
traditional method and get a bigger
return a bigger check at close of escrow
those are two big questions you have to
answer right off the bat well i want a
bigger check
most people do yeah i want more money in
my pocket yeah and
they get confused the i buyers the
people who are out there selling will
tell you you're gonna get market value
but it's not retail market value it's
wholesale market value you're selling to
somebody who's going to sell it for
profit so they got to make some money
somehow so it's going to be a gap there
well if someone's thinking thinking
about selling their home right now
should they sit on it a little bit
longer is the prices value still going
up or kind of plateaued good question
you know that we're still going up as a
matter of fact i just looked at the
stats this week uh the inventory dropped
again so we've got it's a strong
seller's market it should continue to be
so but i don't know that a seller or a
buyer should wait for market conditions
because it's always about your own
personal individual needs if you need or
want to sell now let's go ahead and sell
because you'll be able to take advantage
of that on the buy if you wait to sell
for a bigger price down you're going to
pay a bigger price later on the buy also
okay if someone selling their home do
you have to be out by a certain date is
there 30 days 90 days can you right in
the closet listen i want to sell my home
but i want to be in it until june can
you do that the good news right now is
you could write at least some extension
now some lenders don't like to go beyond
90 days i believe is the limit that they
like to allow a seller to stay in home
after close of escrow but you can do
that and sometimes the buyer lets you
stay there for free sometimes they want
to per diem a little bit of rent back
because they're they're starting to pay
mortgages and such but absolutely we and
as a in a seller's market you have a lot
of leverage so yeah you can usually ask
for those things so we are still it's
definitely still a seller's market
absolutely no question about it what can
someone do if they're planning on
selling their homes to kind of maximize
their profits what can they do if
someone puts in a new backyard is the
value of their home going to go up what
are certain things they can do that's a
great question you watch all these tv
shows and they spend a ton of money
trying to improve their home sale i
don't think you need to do all those
things you do some things make sure
first of all the home is clean make sure
it's decluttered make sure everything
works in it and make sure you have a
good first impression make sure that
curb appeal is there you do those things
and you're going to get maximum dollars
now as you as a realtor and you go up to
i'm selling my home and you pull up and
you realize there's a couple things i
could tweak do you point that out and
say listen maybe you should trim that
grass before we absolutely when you hire
me as your realtor and you hire any good
realtor they're going to go through the
home and tell you what they think you
need to do to maximize your value and
the impact on that value sometimes a
coat of paint although it might cost a
few thousand dollars might return ten
thousand dollars in the sale price so it
depends upon the item in the house each
each deal is different the stories that
i hear people uh you know people coming
from california buying homes with cash
is that actually happening right now
absolutely happening a lot of people
from california a lot of people from all
over the country but especially
california and yeah there's a lot of
cash purchases more than 30 percent of
our single-family home sales uh this
past quarter worth were cash purchases
30 that's a lot now someone is not
that's watching right now that's not in
that i don't know that league of buying
a home with cash and stuff is there
still hope for them to buy a house oh
absolutely yeah you know first of all go
to your lender first get pre-approved
yes get yourself a good strong letter
from your lender the seller always wants
the most money so a cash buyer may have
an advantage in terms of the terms of
the loan of the purchase but even if you
have a loan you can offer them a little
bit more money
that check at close the vessel is really
important to sellers i love it harry
you're so informative we appreciate it
so much my pleasure always always happy
to be here love it harvey thank you so
much and thank you to las vegas real
estate now for sponsoring this segment
for more information give them a call at
702-203-1165 or visit las vegas
lasvegasrealestateradio.com jillian